[Music]
to me this is i think people have
thought of them as like the pepper and
the salt
to me this is the steak yeah you know
like being on time or
taking good notes or being like that's
the salt and pepper that's the commodity
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
welcome everybody joe tarnowski and with
ecrm and i are back with me
gary vaynerchuk entrepreneur investor
and best-selling author
gary thanks for joining us thanks for
having me
so you're a big believer in emotional
intelligence in fact you have a book
coming out in november
that's all about leveraging emotional
skills for business success
why is eq so important because i think
it's real life
you know i think a lot of things that
were taught around business business
school
are uh the hard skills they matter you
need to know how to
balance a checkbook you need to know how
to
staff and models and all that it's very
important but at the end of the day
i really think businesses run by people
with people
for people and humanity and
and the things that trigger people
positively and negatively
are incredibly important and leadership
uh capabilities that find the balance
between
actually executing something because
business is a competitive world
um and uh
and um
[Music]
you know and and then you know actually
having the humanity
to make those things happen matters
now you mentioned like you said it's not
taught in business school so
how do you go about figuring out or or
how much i eq somebody has
and are there certain roles that are
better for high
i eq people versus low eq people
um i think uh i think
every role is important i actually think
the ceo is the number one person you'd
like to have eq
because if she or he doesn't they're
vulnerable
you know i there's no really way to
measure it's not like we have a
test like a cova test or an sat
where you can really get that answer i
think um
i'm a big fan of trying to get
real feedback from human beings that
interact with human beings
you know so when i'm making decisions on
hiring
i try to see if i can find a person or
two that's close to that person
that doesn't have a horse in the race
that's worked with them in the past the
real real
um and then you just observe it when
they work for you
you know the way i pick managers are the
ones who have
you know these emotional intelligence
skills but you know listen there's some
very aggressive emotional intelligence
skills that matter
ambition matters for example you know
one of the
traits i talk about in the book is
ambition ambition matters like somebody
that's hungry is going to
achieve more it's just you know ambition
over passiveness is a factor in winning
but but so is accountability so you have
ambitious people who don't like
accountability
they like to blame everybody else they
like fingers not thumbs
um so some of these skills kind of uh
contrast with each other yeah i think so
like you know to me
being content and being in like my life
wild levels of complacent i wouldn't
call complacency i call it content
i'm incredibly grateful but actually
that's the one i use now but gratitude
and ambition could seem as a
contradiction
i'm so grateful for everything i have
and don't have any expectations
no entitlement to more but have
incredible drive
for more right yep so i think yes i do
think you know
uh kindness and empathy confuse people i
laugh when people
are confused by that right um curiosity
is actually a heavy and humility two
things i talk a lot about
being curious and being humble but at
the same token
conviction so i'm incredibly curious
but i have wild conviction you know
humility
is my ultimate pillar of why i think i'm
here today and being honored to
interview with you and all the good
things that are happening to me
but i have crazy conviction once i
believe something because i've tested
and learned it was cured
so i i think these things do battle
against each other
you know patience and tenacity are two
of the ingredients i talk about all the
time
imagine being equally patient and
tenacious
patience for me is a macro tenacity is a
micro
right so you have to be tenacious in the
task at hand
but patient in the overall mission and i
think people struggle with the levels
they struggle with the macro micro
gotcha so you may have one level of
one and then a lower level of the other
and it kind of works together
that's right and and one may be
something about life and another might
be the project at hand
gotcha so um you referred to empathy
as the swiss army knife of business
tools that can be used to motivate
employees
close sales create new products deliver
world-class service
how should one employ empathy both in
dealing with their customers
but also within their organizations well
to me
it's funny i have more i have more
empathy for my employees than i do for
my customers
and i have more empathy for my customers
customers than i do for my customers
you know i think people have the
rankings wrong i go
employee customer of comp this is at
vayner because we're b2b
employee customer of customer like the
customers of budweiser
and then the client most places are
client client client
and i think that hurts them so for me
that's how i think about it
and i'm just incredibly passionate about
it
i think that if you care and know what
your employee cares about you can create
a system
that allows them to be happy and succeed
i mean when you most businesses are
selling
really that the byproduct of their
success is predicated on their people
i don't know how people don't see that
i'm sure they think people are
interchangeable i do not
yep it's all about people doing business
with people
and it's funny uh i was reading every
year i read marcus aurelius
meditations and it just so happened that
the part i got up to today
he wrote patience uh practice really
hearing what people say
do your best to get inside their minds
so empathy the value of empathy has been
around
for a thousand more than a thousand
years so it's just interesting
how and listening is such an important
part of it listening and
observing um it's just so damn obvious
but we don't talk about it in business
right even right now
i just had to reply to somebody whose
mother is sick that works
that was what i was just doing on my
phone right i'm in the middle of this
interview i don't want to be
i don't want to be not paying attention
to this but i've been worrying about
this employee
and like i didn't even want to wait for
a second i want him to feel my
being in it even at the ability of like
having somebody see this and be like oh
why is gary not paying attention for a
second
so i'm willing to take the casualty be
the
front of it and be judged on that so i
can do what i just did
and and what that is that was so meta
but that was an example of
the reality of it all either you're
religious about this
emotional intelligence or you're not
either you're about your employees or
you're not
either you realize that your employees
your customers
the business and then you the
entrepreneur
is fourth and too many people are put
themselves first they want to get a boat
or a house
or you know and that hurts people
so so patience has always been a
challenge for me and
many values do you think that's because
of ambition or do you think that's
because
you wanted to seem successful in front
of other people's eyes
if you really dug deep i i think it's
probably ambition like i
if i want things to happen faster than
and it's hard for me to wait for them
you know and we see a lot of that
a lot of our customers are young
entrepreneurs
and they're really hungry to grow their
business and
what is your advice to to as far as
patients and taking a long-term view
i just don't know anything else my
advice is
if you love it why would you want it to
end
like for me business is my hobby so like
when you go on a skiing trip
like don't you get sad when it's sunday
when you were looking forward to it you
got there thursday and you skied all
weekend
for me that's business this goes back to
my point of people wanting things
or wanting to seem successful instead of
actually being about it
for me patience is a piece of cake it's
the only thing i want to do
i wish everything slowed down now to
your point i i've had very fast
successes in my career
because i use self-awareness i put
myself in good positions
but in the macro i'm patient and and it
leads to a lot of
mental health when you're not anxious
for success
you're happier and that's where that
content comes yeah
and enjoying the process the process of
what you need to do
love it like like everybody wants to
sell their business these days
i never want to sell my business
yeah and and you know i'm with you there
i'm a big believer in passion
um and having passion for what you do
i've never worked
at a job or stayed at a job that i
wasn't passionate
about and that kind of helps you weather
the storms and stuff
i mean look at this i'm getting paid to
interview you
right now how cool is that you know and
and i also believe in eq you know i
reached out to my speaking bureau
vaynerspeaker is my company my speaking
team after our
speech the other day i said hey the
wi-fi was not stable where i was i
couldn't get it there
can you reach out to them maybe we can
and look what you know this is
this is actually caring that's what
we're doing right now
it was a perfect example and that's one
of the reasons why i wanted to talk
about uh
eq today because your vayner speakers
team
you guys demonstrated exactly that and
and it was awesome and it does make a
difference so
i know we're running short on time i
just had two quick uh
questions in addition so the past year
and a half uh
caused a lot of adversity but some
people in organizations fared better
than others so what is the pandemic
pandemic taught us all
about adaptability and resilience
i think it was just you know i think
it's something we've all known people
have talked about being prepared for
you know it's the mike tyson thing
everyone's got a plan to get punched in
the face
i just think this was the first time for
a lot of people that they had to go
through it
you know and and to be honest
financially
unless you were a business that was
incredibly affected by the rules of
covid hairdresser
you know bars there was no question a
lot of people
didn't feel the financial part because
we just printed money
there's a lot of people this was the
greatest vacation of their careers
oh yeah i definitely saw that people
people currently staying at home on
vacation because they're getting paid
more
in unemployment than to get a job yeah
they're having trouble hiring people
because of that that's right
so that's fine i mean i'm not i'm not
overly worried about
socialism capitalism like i think people
get very religious about things they
don't fully
understand to me it's just one big game
of
the world will continue to have twists
and turns are you in the mental capacity
to deal with it
good point so um how do we go about
developing
our soft skills can they be developed
they can be developed i think the first
thing you have to do is acknowledge that
they're important
it starts there i just don't think a lot
of people watching right now even think
it's important
i think it's foofy or they don't think
it's a real thing
or they don't even acknowledge like they
don't even think in terms of
you know do these things matter like
like and i don't blame them like i don't
know that a lot of people have talked
about curiosity or humility or kindness
or self-awareness or optimism
as like core business tenants they've
been flirted around here and there
but to me this is i think people thought
of them as like the pepper and the salt
to me this is the steak yeah you know
like being on time or
taking good notes or being like that's
the salt and pepper that's the commodity
this is the really matters yeah
definitely matters oh last question
physical health how does physical health
support your ability to be emotionally
intelligent because i'd imagine it's
hard it's hard to be um empathetic if
you're sick
yeah if you're sick or stressed out i
think that's right
i think that's all right i think it's
those variables
i think they matter my son's calling me
i gotta grab this i love it
thank you so much take care youtube
bachelor what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you